here's a tricky geometry problem we have  a rectangle that's cut by two circles we  don't know the lengths of any of the  chords but we know the remaining  distances on the right hand side we have  8 26 and 22 and on the left hand side we  have 12 24 and we need to figure out the  length of the third distance so how do  we do that  so here we have a rectangle and we know  that this side will be equal to 12 minus  8 so that will be equal to four  by symmetry the other side of the circle  will have a rectangle of the same  Dimension so then we can figure out this  distance which will be equal to 24 minus  4 which is 20. now construct another  rectangle here this length will be 26  minus 20 so it'll be equal to 6 by  symmetry it'll be there on the other  side of the circle so we have 6 over  here so the final distance we need to  calculate is 22 minus 6 and that gives  us the answer of 16.